developer tango gameworks is best known
for horror games and that might skew
perceptions of its upcoming title
ghostwire tokyo after all both its
previous games the evil within and the
evil within two fall squarely into the
survival horror genre with the first
directed by studio founder shinji mikami
the creator of resident evil but while
ghostwire tokyo was described as
spooky by former creative director kumi
nakamura on stage during e3 2019 when it
was first announced ghostwire tokyo
doesn't seem like a game that's likely
to scare you instead it seems like an
indication that tango game works is
venturing into different areas than what
players might expect a more accurate
description for ghostwire tokyo might be
a first-person shooter with ghosts
compared to tango's previous games it's
far more action oriented while elements
of the supernatural are woven all
through its deserted version of tokyo
the tone isn't one that'll engender fear
in fact the moment moment-to-moment
action of ghostwire tokyo looks like
it'll make you feel pretty capable of
taking on vicious strange and unnerving
spectral foes despite their sometimes
frightening appearances gamespot
recently got to watch about 45 minutes
of ghostwire tokyo in action in a
hands-off preview provided by tango
gameworks the portion of the game we saw
was pretty close to the beginning giving
some tutorial-esque looks at how you'll
explore the game's open world tokyo how
you'll interact with certain features to
increase your elemental powers and what
exactly is going on in its strange story
you play as akito a japanese man trapped
in the shibuya section of tokyo during
what is apparently an attack by a group
of masked cultists the event sees a fog
ripped through the area anyone caught in
it vanishes their bodies disappearing
akito survives this fate thanks to a
spirit named kk a man who was hunting
the cultists before he was apparently
killed somehow kk and akito fuse
together and this fusion protects akito
from the cultist's attacks as well as
allows him to access a supernatural
power called ethereal weaving
that power then allows aikido to draw on
elemental energy firing blasts of power
at phantoms and demons to destroy them
the portion of the game we saw was soon
after the fog had swept through shibuya
with kk guiding akito through the city
to find out what happened and discover a
way to stop the cult leader hanaya
before he died kk and his colleagues had
been hunting for and attempting to stop
the cultists for akito the situation is
personal as he's trying to reach his
sister who has seemingly been threatened
by hanaya and the cult from what we
could glean of the story the demo we
watched picked up soon after akito and
kk first encountered one another with
akito getting the hang of ethereal
weaving for the first time while making
his way through the suddenly vacant city
while tokyo is devoid of life it is full
of strangers or various kinds of ghosts
and phantoms as in most open world games
it looks as though you'll be able to
either fight your way through the
spectres or attempt to avoid them as you
travel through tokyo fighting them
brings on the first-person shooter feel
of the game in which aikido uses kk's
power to fling bursts of elemental
energy at enemies those blasts of energy
damage the strangers until akito is able
to reveal a core within them which he
can then apparently lasso with his
spectral powers and yank out of the
ghosts dispelling them you'll keep your
distance against enemies most of the
time but the creatures we saw in the
short demo consistently worked to close
the gap on aquito to get close enough to
slash him with melee attacks ethereal
weaving helps in this regard too
allowing you to call up an energy shield
to parry the blow and bounce the
stranger back as it attacks parrying is
all about timing and it appears that
much of combat will be about crowd
control knocking enemies back with your
attacks and your shield to keep them
busy until you can damage them enough to
get at their cores the good news is if
you can expose the cores of more than
one enemy at a time you can rip them all
free with the same lasso ghostwire tokyo
is an open world game which means it's
fairly open-ended even as kk guides you
through the main quest though aikido
survived the supernatural fog it lingers
throughout the city at the start of the
game so part of what you'll need to do
as you move around is find tori gates
that have been infested by the cult's
power and use ethereal weaving to clear
them of enemies and then cleanse them
that pushes back the fog in a given area
exposing new opportunities to explore
as you make your way around you'll find
spirits who linger throughout the city
some of them are being caged by
strangers requiring you to fight the
ghosts to free the people within them
you can then use human-shaped paper
dolls called katashiro to absorb the
freed souls to help them get out of
shibuya it looks like you'll absorb
souls into katashiro before taking them
to phone booths that hide secret
technology apparently set up by kk and
his ghost hunter buddies the phone
booths allow you to transfer the spirits
out of the fog area where kk says they
should return to normal from what we can
tell there are quite a few spirits to
save in tokyo but you'll likely unlock
rewards for doing so
other lingering spirits in tokyo serve
as points of contact for side quests the
main thrust of the demo however saw kk
guiding akito back to the spirit's
former apartment there aikido was able
to gather some information about the
cult while also laying claim to a bow
and arrow that aikido was able to infuse
with his power
but as is demonstrated earlier in the
demo hanaya is on to aikito and kkk and
is deploying cultists to stop them as
you explore kk's apartment the entire
place is suddenly sealed by a spectral
barrier trapping you inside while the
cult tries to use its power to collapse
the building around you that forces
akito to climb higher making his way
through the building and other
apartments to destroy magical barrier
stones that power the force field it's
in this portion of the demo that
ghostwire tokyo feels like it's drawing
from some of the same dna as tango
gameworks the evil within games in fact
ghostwire started its life as the evil
within three before it shifted to become
something separate busting through
apartment doors aikido finds himself
entering shifting impossible spaces as
he enters the living room of one
apartment it reverses placing him on the
ceiling with the furniture above his
head opening a closet he finds the
barrier stone across a distant gap with
only a narrow window revealing it a
precisely fired arrow destroys the
barrier stone and suddenly the closet
reverts to its natural state with the
spirit world beyond vanishing as aikido
makes his way higher he soon finds
himself in twisted apartments with
furniture floating in the air where he
has to climb up piece by piece to reach
a higher room and the final barrier
stone with the barrier dispelled aikido
and kk start hunting for the cultists
who cast the spell making their way back
down to the tokyo streets investigation
also seems like it will be a major part
of how you interact with ghostwire tokyo
with akito using a spectral vision power
that highlights the path the man took as
he left the building after trying to get
you killed the demo ends soon after but
the impression it leaves is that you'll
be searching the city for multiple
cultists stopping them and whittling
down their numbers before ultimately
going after hanaya himself while we got
only a small snippet of ghost wire tokyo
what we saw looks like a fascinating mix
of what tango gameworks has become known
for and something wholly new while this
isn't a horror game and it's not a third
person shooter ghostwire does draw on
some of the excellently strange locales
of the evil within and the open world
sensibilities of the evil within two the
combination of real world locales and
supernatural threats looks like it'll
work exceedingly well borrowing shooter
elements players are familiar with and
twisting them to create something fresh
and strange there is a lot about ghost
wire tokyo we don't yet know but our
brief look suggests exploring a
ghost-filled tokyo is going to be a
blast